this we are going to talk about the
science that exists or the absence of
science that doesn't exist yes probably
the lattice or so then the corporate in
the Marvel Universe specifically yes
entire show of spoilers on Marvel and
game and game so if you ever seen any
game yet just shut off the program yeah
done now you should not be one now
laughing now who's left who's just yeah
those people they're gone all right so
let's just talk about it Chuck
yeah so first of all a friend don't get
me started I totally bad that should be
the name of this don't get me started
hold me back I saw the movie of course
yeah and unfortunately I didn't get to
see it in IMAX did you actually go IMAX
few days before it okay exactly and I
tweeted how did you remember my tweet I
saw your tweet where you said I didn't
know there was so many Marvel powder so
many Avengers yes maybe they're not all
Avengers that's weird
there was just so many galaxies are not
well know blue ones and red ones and
silver ones and green ones and three of
them were named Chris you know that's
ready what's what's up with that hmm so
I so here let me just say something nice
about the Marvel Universe before we get
all up in it okay okay of all the
communities of superheroes that exist
okay the Marvel superheroes more than
not derive from some kind of science or
scientific principle if not the people
themselves right be themselves
scientifically literate so you look at
spider-man and he's really spider boy
spider boy spiders lighter kid it's
quite her kid right you know he's in his
science class and he gets bitten by a
radio so it's not that he was you know
sitting with Miss Muffet sitting on her
tuffet he's in science class when this
happens
dr. banner is a medical doctor when he
comes the Hulk Iron Man is iron man he's
a total genius unlike Batman not to put
not to pit DC against Marvel but Batman
is smart but he's not the one inventing
this stuff that makes it powerful
exactly he's got he's got his company
he's got his whole company right that is
it's a producing military contracting
company right with engineers in the silo
doing their work so Iron Man is doing
all his own work so so I applaud Marvel
I don't know where the science is in
Hawkeye okay he's got no powers and I
love watching I love watching Black
Widow
who doesn't love some good martial arts
right but and we don't have to learn
about the science of that because
they're so yeah and they don't have
powers they don't have power they're
just super very good shots yes both of
them they'd be great for like maybe the
biathlon America once again brings home
Olympic gold
thanks to Hawkeye Black Widow but yes
the ninja by a thorn that needs it by
Abdullah so all right oh you have notes
on this no I have questions questions
actually so what we did was this is kind
of like a cosmic where it is kind of
like a cosmic queries cuz we went online
and we solicited questions tell me that
from people who well yeah all right all
right all right
but people who wanted to know and your
thoughts on it they then got to us I
didn't read the comic books you know
really no but they go to see these
movies and they complain that something
was in the comic did that it's like the
people read the novel's before they
becomes the movie they're the ones who
really should never not be allowed in
the theater because whatever I say about
a movie is not as obnoxious as a person
who read the novel first I got to tell
you you're right so one of the things
that people don't know about this is in
in the movie in the comic books
Hulk becomes world breaker Hulk and so
in the movie a Ragnarok where Hulk gets
sent away to another planet for
this is thor ragnarok that's actually a
storyline where a hulk becomes this
world breaker hulk and he becomes this
kind of like gladiator right but then
after that he learns how to separate
Bruce Banner from the Hulk while they
emerged as one and then he becomes kind
of Bruce the broke he's Bruce and Hulk
at the same time and that's what you see
in this movie yes
end game an end game thank you that he
is so that kind of stuff you do see
happening in the movie which I think
it's kind of cool and that's it mrs.
connective tissue but I mean storyline
all the storylines and that's what they
did really well upheld the storytelling
and I think they did a great job with
the storytelling and I think Marvel
stories are better than DC stories
period I don't I don't know if they just
hire better writers what drawn I'm sorry
I mean I don't I don't know if you're a
DC person okay good for you
but uh I think all their storylines in
Marvel are just so much more captivating
and compelling the DC storylines tend to
kind of have like a more magical
mystical comic crap stuff attached to it
I don't know you know that's my opinion
that that means nothing you know that's
how I feel but I we excuse me you tell
me the powers that Wonder Woman wields
are not differently mysterious and
magical from those of Captain Marvel yes
because Diana is a God goddess yes
basically yes all right
and what's that mean I mean that's such
an easy thing to well you know the only
person who's like that is Thor yes Thor
is a God right okay we get it you know
so therefore he does God stays does God
stuff and right and when you and when
you when you when you create a god I
mean it's like okay well yeah I can do
that I'm a god it's to me it's kind of
lazy ooh I'm just saying it's a little
lazy it's like a I don't I don't have a
rebuttal to that it's like you know okay
I'm a god yeah I did that because I'm a
god you know it's like okay so that's
all your powers come from the fact that
you are you know this this deity mm-hmm
all right and and to me I'm like okay
whereas although the science is not
tight or there's no real fidelity to the
science at least in Marvel in Marvel is
a premise at least there's a promise yes
like for instance gamma radiation
creating the Hulk gamma radiation from
what I have learned from you and every
other scientist on this show actually
every time right yes like there's no way
mm-hmm that you could ever experience
gamma radiation and come out walking out
saying are just a little different today
god it's so refreshing that gamma rates
so anyway right so dad's the way up dog
all right so we got these questions and
we always start with patreon do it and
here we go do it Frank Cain which movie
actually represent a time travel more
consistently with modern theories
endgame or back to the future well they
picked what are your feeling I got to go
with well maybe this stuff that happened
in endgame that I didn't fully
understand but Back to the Future Back
to the Future tried to be as consistent
as it possibly could at every turn I'm
talking my back to future one not to
ones that - it's okay and so what I
become a jerk know what your kids oh
it's okay I get me some garbage all
right sorry so so III think now you
could mess you up
which which movie represents time travel
time travel run game are back to the
future okay so end game if I'm to make
that internally consistent it requires a
much more complex set of timelines
branching off of one another than what
happened in Back to the Future all that
happened - back to the futures they
created all in a single alternative
timeline correct which is kind of the
timeline we wanted there to have been
all along all right and so it had very
satisfying elements to it
in in in in endgame I mean just think
about the multiple timelines forget the
fact that Captain America decided to
hang with his woman and not do all the
saving that he did in the other movies
as Captain America in present-day
okay there's still the present-day
element of this that now is lost to some
timeline that doesn't now exist in the
timeline we are left with he's sitting
there as an old man on a bench and we're
happy for him because he went back to
the true love of his life found his
found this woman you can't you know
we're not gonna you can't hate on me you
can't hate on that's very hard but how
about the whatever crime he stopped
right episodes he was in right what of
that well that's just some other
universe that's unfolding that way
well at this point because you didn't
you didn't change the timeline you
branched the timeline right that's the
the modern concept of what happens when
you change time and so plus I didn't
like the fact that they interacted with
each other he's admiring his own ass
yeah I can't really blame him first of
all he's fantastic and he's admire and
by the way when I saw that scene where
he's knocked down on the ground of
course he's gonna get back up and the
the the second version of him walks by
yeah the American ass is a good ass I
looked at the answer I said that looks a
little too big for what I remembered it
to look like when he's walking around oh
okay you think they had a stunt
I understood or duty or they put but
bloody inserts right I said that looks a
little too large and I said that looks
suspiciously large they're probably
going to comment on it and sure enough
he comments on it nice so so I saw that
coming so anyway you can't interact with
yourself because you don't know what
influence you would have on the world
that was gonna happen that you're trying
to stop right so that's just outright
dangerous yeah it doesn't make sense to
do that and with Marty he sees himself
Marty in Back to the Future right let's
go to the very end of the movie right
where he comes back he's at the rim of
the parking lot sees the future unfold
he's
not interacting with himself no not
technically yes light beams are
exchanging and molecules are there but
in any traditional storytelling sense
he's not interacting with himself so you
can get away with that but here here is
Captain America walking right by himself
and and and more than one of those kinds
of moments happens in this movie so I
didn't I didn't like that
a lot of those moments happen I don't
believe me I'll tell you this my stuff
well I did appreciate him being in the
elevator and going hail Hydra
that was pretty cool okay whispering
that and whispering and that was quite
give me some work ah here we go where do
you believe vibranium falls on the
periodic table of elements why would it
be so strong then so vibranium the
mythical know what we're talking about
here yeah oh oh that's right that's
right
excuse me that's right I forgot the
inner sanctum yeah we don't have to
worry about the Marvel Universe you
don't have to be mr. explanatory Chuck
nice which is a very pedagogical of you
but not in this moment there we go so so
are you familiar with go ahead the
periodic table of fictional elements oh
well it's online
check it out yes it's all there so so
think ilium is there then kill you think
kill him that's an element on the
original I Dream of Jeannie they needed
an ingot of think helium okay
there is the stuff that was in the the
absent-minded professor the what is the
flubber flubber flowers on the periodic
table of fictional materials and it's
full they got a full periodic table cool
and so so so I'd love it I hope they
also have unobtainium from avatar from
Avatar it's avatar so all these elements
are there so people have thought about
how one might organize them I can tell
you this one of the remarkable things
about this universe and the periodic
table of elements in particular is that
from element to element the properties
can be so different from one another
that it is not completely crazy that you
just have an element that has all the
properties of vibranium you know you can
take you could
take a cubic inch of gold okay and
Hammer it's so thin that you could like
gild an entire football field with it so
gold is the most malleable element right
okay now I got to double check my
calculation on that if it's not a
football fitness I'm at nearly as big
okay and that's why you guild things
with gold right yeah okay because you
don't take much of it it looks like you
have a lot I mean you can make it so
thin that you can actually brush it on
two surfaces and they and gold leafing
yes you get gold even okay so so you
look at the the diversity of properties
of elements on the periodic table not
only that the diversity of molecules you
can make with the elements Wow here we
have here here we have sodium which is a
metal soft enough that you can cut with
a knife okay and it will and it's
poisonous and it'll explode if you put
it in contact with water and chlorine to
it a deadly gas and you have table salt
okay
I have oxygen promotes combustion okay
promotes combustion then I have hydrogen
and explosive gas put them together you
make water puts out fire right so this
diversity of properties to tell you that
vibranium is one of the most inventive
realistic things you can think of on
there it's got all these properties that
know what nothing else has right that's
true with anything else that its
properties that nothing else has right
good that is I'm cool with vibranium
that is a great answer deep what you
came from the mother country the mother
motherland of us all that's right yes
okay Chuck we got to take a break okay
so when we come back more squares of
Avengers and on Startalk
so to help us answer some of these
questions yes Pano's mess with the world
yes he did a big way I've got a friend
and colleague of mine from the American
Museum of Natural History
raehwan grant ray welcome to Startalk I
think this is your first time right very
first time not the walls so this is you
are a large carnivore navour ecologist
oh I don't know what that is Wow I kind
of did that I'm not sure what are these
either but I like it well but more
broadly you care about the environment
and the intersection of life and food
chain and this sort of thing and so
we've got some questions and by the way
everyone is assumed to have seen the
movie here so don't worry about spoiling
anything yeah this is advertised as
spoiler alert for Avengers endgame and
that's where these questions are coming
from but I hope I don't get kicked off
because I haven't I haven't seen it yet
all in the authorities that is that's
gonna make this so much better carry on
this okay go what do you have so guess
what you'll probably be able to answer
these questions anyway just from your
professional point of view yes all right
Billy games from Instagram wants to know
this ray I think you're gonna need more
than one episode for this topic is what
he says and more specialists in
different fields lol what the hell was
that
where's a question he didn't finish it
what's the question there is no question
it just goes off that's it okay so see
how easy that was alright here we go
Abbey from facebook says so what would
happen if to the ecosystem if half of
all life was suddenly disappeared
because the bad guy on the Avengers end
game snap well in the previous movie he
snaps his fingers and half of all life
goes away and in his warped sense of
justice he is trying to help the other
half survive so that there's sufficient
resources for them
now they didn't make it clear whether
they killed all half of all plant life
as well right yeah he just slant lies he
was also alive but if his if his killing
half a worm I was gonna say if his
reasoning is that he wants to increase
resources then you wouldn't want to kill
half of our plant life because that's a
resource right for the for the animals
for the ants so these also killing half
the animals I didn't make that clear and
I don't know if what they did in the
comic book but let me just ask you if
you take half of any animal species
that's in equilibrium with its
environment let's start with an
equilibrium case it's an equilibrium you
take away half of them what happens
that's a good cat yeah yeah we're in
perfect balance and then you just cut
that balance in half right what happens
sure a lot of things happen and I just
want to be clear this is just the animal
species right not plants
let's assume that they didn't cut the
plant so yeah let's leave the plants it
makes a big difference you know a
phenomenon that might be potentially
very helpful to the planet
because that's what he says that's what
Santa said well the movie is fairly
accurate in terms of how its portrayed
from what I've heard and what would
happen is that everything would be cut
in half so we'd see a tremendous loss
you know people would be traumatized
there would be a lot of other kind of
large-brained animals that would be
traumatized right like the whales and
the elephants and the gorillas that
we've noticed an exhibit emotions
similar to people and also grieve they
grieve death as elephants grieve death
so do gorillas and other Apes but go
ahead
right right we've even seen them shed
tears and cry inside situations so there
would be trauma right and so for some
species that might actually impact what
happens next in terms of the future of
the species right but in general what's
gonna happen is a whole lot of
reproduction and remembering that
reproduction is different for different
types of species so something like a
whale might reproduce only a couple of
times in its life but something like a
bacteria which is argue
we you know one of these small living
organisms will reproduce like that and
especially with extra space which means
less competition for resources we might
actually see a huge spike in some
populations of animal species so if you
think about if you have a small
population of deer or some kind of
herbivore and a huge meadow full of food
food for them to graze in they're gonna
get bigger and fatter and in the
ecological world that means more fit and
so when they're more fit they're better
able to give birth probably younger
probably more often in their lifetime
and put more genes into the gene pool so
we'll see a huge spike in populations
maybe even beyond what ecologists call a
carrying capacity carrying capacity is a
term that we hear right now a lot when
we talk about the human population of
the world and whether we're each
carrying capacity is Earth past carrying
capacity the number of people or the
number of this would be the maximum
number of people you would sing that's
what you're saying maximum number for
for the resource load for the
availability of resource is the maximum
number to stay in that equilibrium so
what often happens is will see a
population actually spike an overshoot
carrying capacity and then we'll see
another kind of mass death event and
that'll get back into equilibrium so it
would actually technically be kind of an
ecologists dream to see this happen
especially in theory because we'd be
able to test out a lot of our theories
so it would overshoot it would overshoot
yeah my prediction is that depending you
know different species and different
populations of organisms would overshoot
at different times so like I'm saying
like a deer population herbivores would
probably get there quicker than like
whales or elephants or people even
rabbits would get there first when you
see with with so I guess that means that
you would not see the same resulting
population explosion or at least you
know a different mix a different mix
mixer of animals right because for
instance if you see a proliferation of
rabbits or small rodents right then
wouldn't you see a proliferation of owls
or coyotes or their natural predators as
well because these guys are now gonna be
well-fed - absolutely the animal
community all depends on resources and
what I mean resources I mean food and
shelter
seems like shelter isn't gonna be cut in
half right all of those abiotic
resources water you know ground rocks
that kind of thing that's all gonna
still be there so there's gonna be
plenty of shelter for everyone all the
owls all the Fox all them but a lot more
food especially in the terms of plants
for the herbivores and then more
herbivores for the carnivores so I think
that life will go on just fine and it
would be really interesting to watch
there was a sec a part of the movie you
may remember where they said well how
has the earth been since this is Sibylle
the waters cleaner the air is cleaner
they went down the list of all the the
bad things we humans have done to the
earth right and it all got cleaned up
yeah yes just by us not being here we
didn't have to do anything just about
exactly it's like an [ __ ] at a party
you know what I mean once he's leave
well the party's great who know that
this guy was ruining the party all right
another question this is 33 Kyle Alford
from Instagram says if Thanos had used
the stones to shrink all living
creatures to half the size would that
theoretically have had the same positive
effect on the allocation of resources
yes collage eclis right so little people
don't use this much stuff half as much
resources so do you think that would
have the same effect it would have a
profound effect and again it all depends
and if we're including plants as these
resources do animals just animals for
now you know that makes me concerned
because big plants like trees and such
and tiny animals might have a pretty
significant mismatch for a lot of the
needs of those animals I'm kind of
putting humans aside because I think
little humans would probably be fine
we'd figure it out but if little humans
are eating gigantic carrots and stuff
like that it might actually be
good for us right like more food to go
around but a lot of animals depend on
the right size and ratio of plants so if
you think of like insects right I guess
they're technically animals and so if we
have these teeny tiny little bees but
giant flowers it might actually disrupt
a lot of important pollination that we
as people to fund on so there is
something very important about
maintaining size ratios I'll just think
that's this guy stuff you guys think
about like professionally I mean you
know all right ray thanks for being on
Startalk ray it's just great to have you
at arm's reach here even though you're
on skype you're in Washington right now
but next time you're in town we'll get
you live on the show and talk more about
this stuff thank you excellent thank you
bye so she's in Washington cuz she's a
fellow with the National Geographic
Society very cool as well as being a
visiting scientist here nice got more
from me Chuck yes we do Wellesley
Wellesley Tang says hi dr. Tyson and mr.
nice really I'm Wellesley hailing from
New Jersey the question for both of you
if you had the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet what would you do wow so the
Infinity Gauntlet gives you pretty much
the power to do anything that you can
conceive of in your mind I know so
that's that's dangerous powers power
that's too much power that's way too
much but it's unrestricted power it is
it is it's beyond godlike right because
even God has rules right the Infinity
Gauntlet basically says there are no
right if you're doing whatever you want
God created the universe with the rules
that are in it all right this is like a
Spinoza universe where there's the laws
of gravity in quantum physics right and
it was a rule and those are rules and if
you have the if you've got the all the
stones lined up then even the laws of
the universe
don't block containing right so you
could do anything that's wild okay
here's what I would do you ready I would
do all I can to increase
happiness interesting now but now I'm
gonna I'm gonna get philosophical with
you would you increase happiness as a
result of circumstance which means that
everyone finds happiness in their life
on their own or would you just make
people happy so why are you getting deep
okay I think I I'm very in yang on this
okay I don't think you can know
happiness fully without having never
seen sadness interesting and it's I
agree this is why rich people can get
very upset over things that poor people
can't even imagine having gotten ups
getting upset about my god the vowels in
the shop again the vulva not my box but
I can't believe why do you sound like
Thurston Howell is my favorite person so
that so it would be it would be I don't
have the recipe for how I would make
that happen
okay no in my day I try to make sure
there's somebody out there that's
slightly happier because I exist in this
world today that's nice and if what it
is is helping them across the street I
don't know anything simple so it would
be awkward in the movie with Jim Carrey
with God what's the name of that one ah
Bruce Almighty Bruce Almighty in that
film mm-hmm
Jim Carrey becomes God temporarily yes
and he just helps people in ways with
blanket decisions and realize it has
consequences great and and you know if
you don't really think it through
completely the actor trying to help
everybody ends up hurting everyone right
right right
so I I I'd have to really think that
through but I would want to increase the
amount of total happiness in the world
because misery is something that humans
have lived too long with yeah
interesting yeah I wouldn't miss 76ers
win a championship all right here we go
I have them play the Knicks and have the
Knicks win since I was in Middle School
okay yeah all right here we go
the one thing this is far Dahlstrom
Farrer Dahlstrom says this one thing
that bugged me about the movie half the
population is gone on earth we must have
changed our agriculture for that then
suddenly they come back wouldn't that
lead to world starvation I think if you
get rid of half the people half of those
people are gonna be some of those people
are gonna be farmers something I mean
think of the people who are producing
the products that feed the rest of us so
if you have a farm that requires a
hundred people to run and you kill half
the people the remaining 50 can't now
run the farm at all because everybody
has their job right you need farms half
the size so yeah I think Fanus really
didn't think this through you know and
that's what kills me if that house is an
idiot is really just a stupid stupid man
he's an idiot idiot yeah um I think I'm
uh I'm really a good nice to people
through those that survive exactly I'm
hoping that helped you all my destiny
has been to help you all and it's like
no bro no all right here's here this is
Darryl Tim and I tweeted right when I
saw the film that the the amount of
resources in the universe if you are
spacefaring is essentially unlimited
right so forget that the fact that
you're running out of resources on earth
if you have access to space space big
asteroids and comets and meteors and all
the rest of that come on now yeah by the
way how about that how about it's just
like I'm gonna snap my fingers and take
care of everybody thank you why do I
have to eliminate have to why don't I
snap my fingers and provide for
everybody I'm doing to snap my fingers
we're gonna have quadruple the resources
which means and it take those four times
as long and then you call me when you're
done right exactly right all right
Thanos you're a dick
okay so this is Darryl Tim fat and in
fact yes okay how is Captain Marvel
apparently able to travel faster than
light to save the day in the final
battle and also have a beeper that
consider her wife sees in other galaxies
that's so weird
so it seems to me that Captain Marvel
yes is supremely powerful on a level
that should preclude the need for any
other avenger well yeah why do I need
someone who shoots bows and arrows when
I have Captain Marvel what why do you
why do I need vibranium if I have
Captain Marvel why do I need iron man
who can fly with Jets when she can move
through the vacuum of space what a
spacesuit without a spacesuit yeah why
do I need a Hulk who smashes things when
captain why do I need any other Avenger
other than Captain Marvel
plus she glows yes what else do you need
you don't need anything now here I have
issues that's a prison alibi that's a
glow that's her personality yes yes
that's so I don't plus if she has that
much power how is it that she couldn't
move the glove from one side of the
battlefield to the minivan that's that
just really pissed GM carry spaceships
across the galaxy yes Lance oh man
softly okay touch three three points off
land soft landing a spaceship a thousand
times bigger than she is right she can't
move a globe across a battlefield to a
minivan I gotta say that was really very
that like that's one of those movie
mechanisms where you're like come on I
know right is this that this is the most
creative you could be right how to stuff
it's like it's like her running away
from it and then tripping on it on a on
a rock right or something yeah I mean it
would be it would have been far more
cool if Thanos like summon like a
thousand of those little minions to hit
or all at once all at once or something
like that commensurate with her power
her power yes Oh
what the hell I could fly through space
you know yeah yeah so alright so now if
you want her to move through space you
can imagine that she quantum teleports
alright okay
I don't you knew this but I I'll explain
this do you want the Flex I want this
you want the full explanation why not
okay so um if you put water in a glass
mm-hmm it can't get out because the
glass has walls right okay
so the walls are boundaries between the
location of the water and the table
right does it make sense that if the
walls were not there the water would
then settle down and spill all over the
table that's obvious of course so what
that means is the water has a lower
energy state it could occupy but the
walls are preventing it okay because if
you move the walls of water won't stay
there it goes on its own right it's
called a lower energy State
okay oh by the way the table is higher
than the ground if you put a crack in
the table it'll go through the table and
hit the ground right it prefers to be
even on the ground right then it does to
be on the top of the table that it did
to be in your water glass okay quantum
mechanically you can trap a particle
with the walls of a glass it's a it's
it's a it's a energy well okay okay you
can trap it there well sorry let's look
at just the world or a marble stuck in a
little in a in a in a like a a
skateboard park and the marble could
roll up and down back and forth back and
forth there it is right it's not leaving
okay if you want it to leave push it
with fast enough energy enough energy so
it goes over the top and then it goes
down to the ground level right but you
have to give it energy to get over that
barrier right to then escape and now it
escapes okay watch it turns out because
particles can also be waves hmm the
particle that's trapped in the well is
also a wave that exists not only
everywhere in the well parts of that
wave exists outside the well so the
particle has a chance a small chance of
this ting outside of the well a very
high chance of existing in the world so
most of the times you look at the
particle is inside the well every now
and then it is outside correct to watch
it escape it escapes instantly it breaks
through the barrier and no matter the
width of that battery barrier it goes
from one side of the barrier to the
other in zero time right so if she has
control over the quantum continuum right
she can then base it's called tunneling
she could tunnel through any space
barrier and be wherever she wants in the
universe instantaneously so she would be
in effect entangled with the entire
universe very clever yes that would be a
way to have her move through space in
the way that she does Wow
she would be quantum entangled with
every limitation so that she could then
materialize herself wherever she needs
to be Wow having tunneled there through
these barriers correct that's pretty
wild right that's but she still can't
move a damn glove into a minivan damn
galaxy oh my god all right Nick wow that
was great okay cool okay Ron Sparkman he
goes at the beginning all here for you
Ron give it to me here we go at the
beginning of the film Tony and nebula
are in space trying to return from a
Saturnian moon so they're in a spaceship
in space right so they're on Titan in
the spaceship in space but moon of
Saturn who's Titan correct and the but
the sky they show makes it look like
they are in deep space what should that
view leaving the saturnians system
actually have looked like like they're
in deep space because if you're not on
earth if you're not on earth then every
place is deep space to you right there's
nothing attenuating your view there's no
the weather yes there's space gas clouds
but there's no atmosphere you're trying
to look
as you have here on earth so once or the
only difference is the Sun is relatively
nearby so don't look that way that'd be
too bright right that wouldn't that
would knock out some of your view
because it would be too bright and
you're like too much light too much
light you look the opposite direction it
will look as though you were some
anywhere else in the galaxy be a space
for you it's very beautiful that's gotta
be amazing yes and have a ring system
that you're pulling away from oh it's
beautiful oh now I want to go to Saturn
dude do you know yes Edgar Mitchell okay
recently died a couple years ago okay
Paul Paul 14 astronaut all right
we're losing him and they're not getting
replaced cuz nobody's been anywhere
outside of lower authorities gone yeah
since 1972 so this is the only people
have left earth for a destination Edgar
Mitchell on the way back was positioned
in back from the moon was a position in
the capsule in such a way that the
rotation of the capsule always had the
plane of the solar system in view Wow so
as he rotated earth would go by and the
moon and the Sun and the planets three
days of this Wow this changed him I'm
sort of dead he became busy
apart from the throwing up he he became
spiritual okay he was connecting to the
cosmos in ways no one else ever had or
perhaps ever will
yeah and he'd stand he started
participating in these sort of
Institute's where people are wondering
is there some other spiritual way of
knowing about the world other than just
our mechanical ways at a lab table right
and so my point is if you're out there
and you see Saturn and its rings and
deep space and the Sun and the rest of
the planets your reaction does not
surprise me and you didn't even witness
that right right and I saw it on IMAX
that was really good but if you see that
stuff for real life you're a different
person coming back
I believe it
that was different when I saw a Saturn
from basically a backyard telescope
because you can actually see the rings
of the rings of Saturn and it's moved so
it's really wild and it's it's that's
why my desk lamp to this day is Saturn I
siesta - I made when I was in seventh
grade woodshop class we pressed down the
ring and the light turns on that's that
damn thing still works - that's right
you're in the wrong business no I'm in
the right business Tyson lamps all right
that's been my desk lamp since since
middle school ever since I built it in
seventh grade it's really cool - what
else you got now right here we go mmm
thank you Ron here we go this is living
to learn from Instagram says oh this is
so cool what was the whole mobius strip
thing so remember Tony he figures out
the quantum key to time travel by asking
jarvis for a mobius strip and then he
actually calculates something using the
movie stripped and I don't know from
there I'm like okay yeah I don't know if
there was any real sign okay after that
so it's called gobbledygook special kind
of movie science right so there is such
a thing as a mobius strip okay and a
mobius strip is a fascinating thing it's
a fascinating thing if you want to make
one cut a ribbon so a long thin strip
strip the ribbon like any of any length
doesn't matter okay okay maybe make one
a foot long just to fruit second and
maybe two inches wide okay and then you
could tape the ends together to make a
loop all right okay not the sides
together there make a long cylinder just
tape the two four ends that would make a
loop right okay right and and and that's
nothing odd about a loop no there's an
inside of the loop and the outside on so
you can paint the inside if you wanted
okay and paint the outside all right
okay instead this time instead of
connecting them that way give one of
those edges a turn
okay okay one hundred eight hundred
Whitley twist twist then tape them
together so now what you have is kind of
an s-shaped like almost like figure
eight that turns in and out on itself it
is so it goes way turn and it goes out
it is way more profound than that okay
okay you ready go ahead that thing has
only one side you could draw a line
along the length of it as you pull the
ribbon through and without ever lifting
your pencil off the page without ever
crossing the edge of the page you will
land back where you started and you
would have put a line on all surfaces of
it it is it is a ribbon that has only
one side and if you cut along that line
if you cut it in half along the line you
just drew uh-huh you make a single loop
twice as big you don't cut it into two
politics oh oh wait so so it just
becomes wait a minute maybe you feel
pretty visual visual dude oh I'm seeing
because what's happening is the twist
now as you cut as it opens up it just
becomes a circle a bigger circle okay
that's what is this is a big circle okay
so now the point is so you thrown a
mobius strip which is cool and has a
dimensionality interest to it okay okay
but then you put a time-travel spin on
it right alright so if your path through
time is on a mobius strip you can come
back to where you were but you're not
exactly where you were you're on the
other side space right even though it
only has one side
[Music]
oh look at that oh I see what they did
there all right so so if you had to
create mumbo jumbo gobbledygook obvious
removing way to go mobius strip we'll
get that for you and so you come back
and you are right adjacent to that other
part of the universe except you have no
access yet until you go back around and
that's how the idea I'm thinking I'm
just trying to get that perfect sense
right but it makes no sense in terms of
time travel
well it just makes philosophical sense
in terms of you need returning to them
with some hocus pocus mumbo jumbo why
not
why not do it by the way there's three
dimensional mobius strips oh the whole
klein bottles yes now I've heard of that
heard of a Klein bottle bottle that
actually has no inside whereas the
inside is also the outside in this you
know in four dimensions so the Klein
bottle you build in three dimensions is
what it would look like projected onto
three dimensions from a four dimensional
space interesting Wow Chuck we have
hardly any time left I'm doing a
lightning round let's do it okay here we
go go all right this is John C he says
what is the biggest scientific
inaccuracy in the movie in your
estimation in accuracy so I know I'm
typecast that way but that's not how I
think of movies I think of were they
internally consistent in the wrong
science that taraf okay right and if
that did you give them shout out for at
least hey listen right we we actually
took the science and tried it too it's
awful conclusion right but we stay
consistent to that awful okay so here it
is on all the spaceships they know made
no reference of any gravity generator
and they all should have been weightless
on their spaceship or it happened that's
loading through space or yeah but they
didn't show that right we giving a shout
out to and right nobody nobody was
weightless at any time never and the
weight matters because you could be
standing upside down in the ship and and
if it's rotating all of that works they
then give any thought to that especially
the guardians of the galaxy people okay
or what it creatures right right yeah
all right that's great okay that's and
that's so that's a good milky blue moon
wants to know this how is it that the
cap as in Captain America can throw his
shield and it comes back to him like a
boomerang
cuz it is a frisbee well wait wait I
thought it doesn't just come back to it
bounces off of things back to him that's
what I thought it right it doesn't just
come back like it's on a yo-yo
no he throws it it hits its target and
it comes back to him otherwise he'd have
to run after it every time he threw it
you know what I don't know right so
you're right oh maybe if there's a
saying facing you there will always be
an angle with which you can throw
something weird bounces straight back to
you so he's just good at pool he's good
it he's good at the cue shot exactly the
cue ball shots banking stuff right I
don't I never remember seeing it just go
frisbee with himself or boomerang with
himself right it hits something and
comes back okay good unless I've missed
a movie that he was in where he did that
okay
next plus it's very boy knee right it's
very boy knee right so it'll it'll go
and then retain the energy that's coil
energy and come back on that okay next
Ryan Lenny from Instagram wants to know
this why didn't ant-man go up thanasis
but like you said I said like okay
pretty funny you'll have to wait for the
director's cut the after-hours
director's cut on that one all right
last one
Carlos francelli from Instagram says
this Tony Stark says something like the
Planck scale messes with the Deutsch
proposition creates the EPR paradox so
what okay forgive me I don't know what
the Dortch proposition is but he did
mention the EPR paradox which is the
einstein-podolsky-rosen paradox that's a
real thing okay dad
Einstein is Einstein the other two or
other physicists and they got together
and explored in the discovery and the
dawn of quantum mechanics is like this
is some weird stuff is it real right can
we create a thought experiment that is a
paradox that will reveal either a new
truth or unravel the truth that we think
we've just discovered interest and so so
I don't know if there's a Deutsch
proposal mm-hmm I think they just threw
that in there if there is I don't know
it okay but EPR is a very well known
paradox so the EPR paradox is real well
no so einstein-podolsky-rosen paradox
they this back in the early days of
quantum
physics where we're really scratching
our heads not we I'm I wasn't there but
my people my physics right you know
progenitors here
the scratching their heads what does it
mean to not be able to fully know the
reality of an object of a particle
Heisenberg noted you can't
simultaneously know the momentum of a
particle or its position precisely at
the same time so Einsteins uncertainty
principle means you can't know with
accuracy the position of a particle and
its momentum which means its velocity in
which which different speed and
direction it's going okay you can't know
both simultaneously the more you know of
one the less you know of the other if
you know the velocity of something you
don't know where it is right if you know
where it is then you know exactly how
fast it's going okay even though you
don't know where it is
this will be good next Chuck next time
you stop for a speeding ticket right and
the cop says do you realize you've been
going sick you're five mile right yeah
but I don't know where I am and if the
cop is is is is quantum physics literate
I bet they let you go yeah that's gonna
happen so they had thought experiments
to explore the nature of that reality
okay and it was confronting all of the
thinkers of the day to sharpen their
ideas about what quantum physics is and
what it could mean so at least they made
an attempt maybe with some real science
yeah it was a gym okay no I could give
me third one that's it we got someone
questions oh my gosh oh wait there's one
more one more go it says Neil I am Groot
that's the question
oh that is a question that's the
question I think most people in life
never really know who they are so that
really at the end of the day we should
be deeply respectful of grewed who does
right because he knows I am Groot that
is a cosmic perspective this hey
is a spoilers version this is the first
ever spoilers versus boilers start
talking yeah we assume you've all seen
endgame and other Avengers movies
related to it so that's what we did we
just spoiled it for you or enlighten you
one or the other yep
we can't spoil if you've already you
already seen that you can't be spoiled
yeah you just been in late right uh so
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist I'm always thanking Chuck
made man is always good to be here
alright as always I did you
[Applause]
you